bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors le gouvernement a
annoncé mardi la création de 240 places
d'hébergement pour les migrants
l'association et hop ya 56 ans avec la
mer en réclame toujours un millier est
ce que l'état a les moyens d'ouvrir
autant de places en si peu de temps
bien entendu il faut tenait compte d'une
variable l'ensemble des hôtels sans cali
morbide
il ya là beaucoup qui sont fermées même
moi même j'ai eu des clients et clientes
mon cabinet il demandeurs d'asile qui
étaient hébergés temporairement
notamment pendant le premier concile
mort donc de 17 mars au dîner par
exemple dans un hôtel à proximité de la
gare de l'est donc avec la volonté
politique ça poserait pas de problèmes
ça peut se permettre ce même
d'indemniser les hôteliers donc c'est la
volonté politique qui fait défaut
alors évidemment encore les hôtels
reprendre leur fonctionnement normal
qu'on la souhaite par ailleurs il
faudrait là des places d'hébergement
mais ça sera d'ici plusieurs mois qui en
comprend bien la situation sanitaire est
à préciser que le la région de berlats
elle elle compte 20000 de tels places
d'hébergement donc bien plus que la
région parisienne mais effectivement
rattrapage donc la création de places
d'hébergement
ça peut prendre plus qu'une semaine mais
là il ya des des locaux qui sont vides
du fait de l'absence ou de la baisse
radicale du tourisme et même d'autres
types de voyage tels que des voyages
d'affaires et donc l'hébergement
d'urgence serait possible sans aucun
problème il a partiellement eu lieu à il
ya eu hébergement il ya mise à l'abri
pendant le premier conflit d'une manière
incomparable avec celle qui a lieu
aujourd'hui ça on parle de 100 mille
logements inoccupés à paris comment se
fait-il alors qu'on a toujours autant de
personnes dans la rue qui passent leurs
nuits dehors parce que ces personnes
n'ont pas accès comme ce soit derrière
des migrants ou y compris de france et
des français qui n'ont pas accès à ces
mouvements là certains les motifs sont
multiples c'est pas le seul motif mais
ladhof certains cas
inoccupé pour faire monter le prix pour
des raisons spéculatives et alors il ya
aussi les propriétaires âgés qui ne sera
pas en mesure de les rénover parfois on
cliente de la responsabilité vis-à-vis
d'un locataire qu'il était il répare
sachant qu'il ya des mécanismes pour ça
aujourd'hui tels que la garantie de
l'état à laquelle on peut avoir recours
mais effectivement il serait possible et
de l'avant de réquisitionner de tels
logements aussi est là pas uniquement
pour la mise à l'abri de gens y compris
pour alors ce n'était pas pour résoudre
même pas en tout cas pour amoindrir la
problématique du logement de l'absence
de logement et du mal logement et de
niveaux parfois délirants des les prix
locatifs au régent par parisien donc
c'est un sujet qui a des liens avec le
sujet de précédents mais effectivement
qui qui se pose de la même manière
emmanuel macron avait déclaré en 2010
est je cite la première bataille c'est
de loger tout le monde dignement je ne
veux plus voir d'ici la fin de l'année
des femmes des hommes dans les rues dans
les bois ou perdus quand on entend quand
on se rappelle de ses propos d' emmanuel
macron du président de la république
sait quel genre de problème c'est
purement politique si le président de la
république lui la nuit mais n'arrive pas
à mettre en place une politique pour
régler ce problème qui le peut alors je
ne suis pas sûr que la volonté y est
souvent vous connaissez le sort des
scores électoraux parce que celui que
vous citez c'était un beau celui que
vous citiez terbel beau slogan électoral
un ancien ministe donateurs a dit un
jour les promesses
les promesses n'engagent d'abord ceux
qui y ont cru je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils
étaient en juillet 2010 sept ans il
avait déjà été élu président il
reprenait un slogan qui l'avait lancé
pendant la campagne 2007 2017
c'était une reprise du corps électoral
et c'était effectivement un engagement
en début de mandat mais je ne suis pas
sûr que la sensibilité du personnage que
vous évoquez aux questions à la question
des inégalités sociales soit elle qui
lie élite tout à volonté
cependant évidemment si volonté
politique il y en avait
dans le doute et ça ne suffisait pas
d'avoir un peu de bonne volonté de se
retrousser les manches
mais évidemment se trouve la question
des inégalités structurelles et des
inégalités spatiales en france il n'y en
a plus que dans les pays comparables
tels que le royaume-uni ou l'allemagne
il n'y a par exemple pas la notion de la
réparation est lourde de sens entre
ville centre ville et banlieue et donc
évidemment la question du logement
sous-entendez question de la question de
l'hébergement d'urgence sous-entend la
question du lien social
alors et devine égalité de revenus
bientôt les vidéos de l'évacuation
musclée à des migrants place de la
république à paris ont choqué une partie
de l'opinion qu'en avez-vous pensé vous
en tant qu'avocat alors les images du 23
novembre n'ont d'abord souk est
également bien premier chef
et deuxièmement il met ses dires elle
ment c'est dire ces images que là il y
avait pour le mois d'un côté
l'utilisation usage disproportionné de
la force de la force publique donc de la
force de la police donc agissement
illégal de la part de la police est
deuxièmement amis il y à aussi
violations des droits fondamentaux je
reprends un contre exemple l'état a été
condamné pour les personnes se trouvant
à l'époque dans la ville d'eau ou dans
les environs de la ville de calais dans
le nord pas de calais donc s'agissant du
migrant par exemple à gong cube qui
cherche à gagner
par la suite le royaume uni l'état a été
condamné par les tribunaux
administratifs par le conseil d'état de
d'effectuer une mise à l'abri et
d'urgence et par exemple de ico prix de
réinstaller sur des terrains de
campements tel que celui qu'on appelle
la jungle qui était accusé d'homicides
est de réinstaller des robinets d'eau
qui avaient été enlevés ou d'y installer
des accès à l'eau courante
parce que des droits fondamentaux des
personnes étaient au courant parce que
dia que même si les personnes sensées
régulière ce qui n'est pas le cas de
tous les migrants du népal ans parce que
certains d'entre eux se trouvent à
procès de la ville d'autres se trouvent
en procédure
dube la même procédure qui comporte des
délais au bout desquels la france
devient responsable de l'eau du
traitement de la demande à lille mais
quelle que soit leur situation personne
dit d'oublier dont la france aura
responsable d'ici quelques mois du
traitement de la demande d'asile devant
de la ville ou même sans papiers donc
personne en situation irrégulière des
personnes en les droits fondamentaux les
les les sans-papiers en des endroits les
eaux premier degré de l'hébergement
d'urgence
donc le l'hébergement de jour en jour
pas pas l'hébergement durable très bien
le plusieurs mois berne a jailli de
droits étaient violés
c'est entendu merci pour cet éclairage
je rappelle que vous êtes avocat au
barreau de paris et spécialiste du droit
des étrangers merci beaucoup